hey guys it is the fifth of februari my
name is jeff mcdonald and you are tuned
into games but news first off the mark
tonight a bunch of people have been
reporting login issues with the ps4
which as you can imagine it spawning a
fair amount of discontent solely absurd
they're totally aware of the issues and
are looking into them apparently they're
mainly affecting the PlayStation Network
and store and that's pretty much the
whole story if you can start a console
war off that one I'll be seriously
impressed music metal gear solid 5 has
been doing the rounds this week as it's
been confirmed that the ground zeroes
campaign is pretty friggin short two
hours of short in fact kazuma
productions designer Jordan Amaro is
defending the length by arguing that
journey and deressa short games and
their masterpieces of video games and
literature not sure about the ladder
myself but the main qualms seems to be
that those games cost around 15 and 10
dollars a piece and ground zeroes is set
to be priced between 20 and 30 bucks for
its different platforms just in case you
didn't know ground zeroes is supposed to
be a prequel prologue to metal gear
solid 5 the phantom pain which is going
to be super huge and super lengthy but
the Metal Gear drama didn't stop there
because resolution gate has struck again
as it's been revealed that the game is
supposed to look better on the ps4 both
the latest issue of game informer and
Hideo Kojima himself said they prefer
ground zeroes on ps4 but only slightly
so don't stress it if that isn't your
console of choice Konami hasn't given us
any info into the resolution and frame
rate differences between the two now
current-gen consoles so we get to look
forward to that crap storm when it all
comes to light unfortunately for
Microsoft if the ps4 does have the
technical one up it won't be the first
time given that cod ghosts Tomb Raider
definitive edition and battlefield 4 are
among the titles that don't run quite as
well on the Xbox one are you guys
bothered by a short game or do you
reckon it's quality over quantity and
let me know your thoughts and feelings
in the comment box below last up
titanfall has been dropping another
truth barnwell respawn try
seriously sugar-coated litterin first it
was the fact that the game wouldn't come
to play station then the number of
player characters in multiplayer and now
it's all come down to EA hate because
titanfall on PC will require origin not
totally sure why that comes as a
surprise since this is an EA game and
unlike Ubisoft with you play they
haven't quite taken the hint over there
wildly unpopular platform just yet are
you reconsidering a Titan for purchase
after this news or are you just gonna
grin and bear it with origin for the
whole 10 seconds of log in you're
actually going to need to use it you can
let me know in the comments down below
or on my twitter where i'm at jeff
mcdonald that's it for me today but i
will be back again tomorrow with some
more news so till then i hope you have a
good one